so I've listed our the sample space that
are all bun now I can use that sample
space you can see I used this to make
this and now I'm going to use this to
answer this question what's the
probability of getting exactly one tail
have a look exactly what so not two or
three which is includes one but not
exactly one so how do can you see them I
can see exactly one tail right as a
person - I could so you'll see the next
question just when you're ready going
thanks
you can see it's usually important to
interpret the question properly yeah and
if you interpret the question
differently you answer the question
right but it'll be the wrong question
okay these three are all of the ones
which had exactly one tail have I missed
any I think I've got them all right now
remember I said I haven't led what any
of these branches because they all have
the same chance right now they all have
the same chance and there are eight at
the bottom sorry at the side is tell me
there are then this should be
individually it should be an eighth
right and this will be an eighth and
this will be do you agree so what's the
probability of getting exactly one time
three are favorable and eight is your
total sample size okay so good now how
long did this last one here again we're
gonna use the same tools tell me what's
the probability he's the question you
maybe with the heel of getting at least
one tail so that's one tail or two tails
for three okay
that means I'm including a whole bunch
more right so you have a look in your
life oh it's
fun and this one and this one it also
includes this one this one this one and
this one now think about this for a
second I could of course just add all of
these off or I could add them all up but
there's something I already know today
that can help me do this in a kind of
quicker way right the probably get at
least one tail
what's the complement of that event
what's the only way to not get at least
one tail sticking no tails right or you
can say an alternative has to get all
heads okay and you can see in the list
that I've got you do you see it right
look this guy here is the complement
okay so at the moment it's just as easy
to say it's seven out of eight okay now
that's very easy here because they all
have the same chance okay but let's get
back to that you know hypothetical
situation I said where it was um what's
it called an unfair coin yeah exactly
okay it's on that's very two-faced right
now this is trickier this is trickier if
I want to work out all these
probabilities now okay thinking about
this for a second because it's not as
likely to get a tail this guy here this
isn't gonna be one out of eight anymore
is it right because it can't be they're
not all the same chance in fact that's
the most unlikely thing to happen do you
agree that how do I work out the
probability of this on my unfair coin am
I gonna do do you remember do you
remember when we are having a look at
the ace of diamonds and the King of
Diamonds do you remember that we looked
at we said look there's the word or is
the way or that means you add them
together good but here this is actually
the way with writer is actually tail and
tail and tail I'm not tail or tail I
want all of them at the same time right
so you can see I've got all here which
means
when you've got and you want them all
combined by multiplication not addition
so look at these guys right 1/3 1/3 1/3
I'm gonna multiply down these branches
right like this what is the probability
I'm multiplying
3rd 2009 and then I do one more time the
probability of getting tails tail tail
is 1 and myself so you can see here I
could do the same thing to work out the
pony of a head head head actually can
you work out the pole yeah I'm glad you
asked right I'm so extending this idea
when you don't see any numbers that
means everything's the same chance ok
but I got really suspicious because on
my first three flips I got three heads
so thought huh maybe it's not a fair
coin okay so therefore if I start to put
numbers on these branches what I'm
indicating is actually then not all the
same chance some things are more likely
to happen than others right so in my
imagine 2 scenario you're twice as
likely to get a head and a tail okay so
therefore that's where these three he's
come from it's not that there are three
possibilities we're saying it's just
more likely right there's a two-thirds
chance I could make an anything I could
make it 4/5 or or 1117 or something like
that these numbers they would come from
an experiment they would come from
experimental probability they're like
well look I just took this many times
and this is what I observed just that
make sense so at the moment my
experiment says you've got a hundred
percent chance of
because really done three fixing the
winds okay so just to finish up they're
probably getting at least one town
here's the way I asked you all to write
a mystery the probability of getting at
least tail this is the compliment this
is what we were saying before is the
compliment of getting all heads so you
give it that like if you get at least
one tail it's the opposite of that it's
getting no tables it's getting more
hands okay
I've run out of space so I'm gonna be a
bit more into this so the property of
getting a head head head on a real coin
on an on a fair coin should be 1/8 right
because all of these are the same in
there April's possibilities so it should
be one takeaway 1/8 right which gives me
as you told me before
it's 7/8 one of the ways to know that
you're doing a profit of the question
right is you can approach it from lots
of different ways you can think about
for what two different angles you still
get the same answer okay if you're
getting different answers from different
ways then something is going wrong and
that's a great way to know I need to
revisit like some assumption may be
correct okay